have another topic squad member of
congresswoman Ilhan Omar turning heads
while campaigning for Bernie Sanders
this weekend watch what kind of world is
she thinking about when I hear her I
just say oh brother you know today we're
talking about I Bernie Sanders was
talking about imperialism right
it's not about imperialism so you
realize his socialist heart isn't really
in Sweden or Denmark it's in the old
Soviet bloc and Cuba we love him as an
adorable cranky Muppet but his ideas are
kind of destructive and when you accuse
anybody of like oh you don't love
America when they are talking about
America as some kind of Western
imperialistic mess there's a valid point
to be made there and they can if they
can't wait to see America fundamentally
changed well I would say that the real
Western Imperius were the French and the
British who really screwed up the entire
map if you look at the Middle East
they're the ones that draw those lines
that we're now defending come on British
way to take it to the Brits I mean
people are right now in Venezuela buying
gas with cigarettes it's ridiculous and
this is why people laugh at him as
eventually being the mainstream
candidate when you throw around the
Western imply it's never gonna happen
and her saying it's never been further
away than my in my lifetime or whatever
refugee to Congress she's like they did
have a big what happened
yeah Marty to me isn't Trump the one who
says America first and trying to get us
out of everything and so well that's no
we're talking about imperialism Dana and
so it seems to me like Trump is saying
hey you know what I don't like this
nation-building stuff I don't like the
idea we get involved as the world's
policemen huh this sounds like the
left-wing version of Trump talking
points Oh interesting so you're saying
that they're actually for Trump 2012 oh
I'm saying it sounds like you're a guy
their point